comme dirait ma mère j'aime bien faire
le clown alors je crois que c'est ça que
je fais le mieux c'est le métier qui m'a
donné cette maison c'est le public alors
quand je peux le week-end je viens comme
comme tous les français
comme tous les parisiens j'essaye de
m'évader ya en général entre huit et
quinze personnes à la maison c'est moi
qui fais le marché il annonça je n'y
connais rien pas trop quand même
voilà mon cher portant mesdames merci
beaucoup
et pourtant vous avez monté un
restaurant
oui mais ça c'est pour des raisons tout
à fait différente j'ai monté un
restaurant parce que quand je sors du
théâtre le soir je ne sais pas où aller
dîner et au moins là je connais un
endroit maintenant
[Musique]
dans ciels de livres jouets plusieurs
époques du même personnage dans la vie
vous avez pianiste vous aimiez les arts
vous êtes quelquefois jardiner quels
rôles préférés vous savez jardinier je
suis pour la télévision parce que je je
connais rien aux plantes ni aux jardins
la musique j'en suis un amateur mais pas
un professionnel
alors je crois que je vais qu'une chose
que j'aime bien c'est faire l'acteur
parce que je crois que je sais un peu et
puis comme dirait ma mère j'aime bien
faire le clown alors je crois que c'est
ça que je fais le mieux est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de votre vie oui enfin je
veux dire que je me fais des reproches
quelquefois parce que je dis que je
m'occupe pas assez des gens qui m'aiment
et qui sont autour de moi alors ça je
suis pas très content de moi parce que
quelquefois je me disais bon le théâtre
c'est bien cinéma c'est bien la
télévision c'est très bien mais là
métier c'est mieux que tout
[Musique]